We have, of course,
today voted also to ensure that Wales becomes the first nation
anywhere in Europe to be LED by a black person.
It is a matter of pride, I believe,
for a modern Wales, but also a daunting responsibility for me,
and one that I do not take likely.
But today we can also expect a depressively familiar pattern to emerge,
with abuse on social media,
racist tropes disguised with polite language,
people questioning my motives.
And, yes,
they will still question or deny my nationality was.
Others will question why I am playing the race card.
To those people, I say once more,
it is very easy not to care about identity
when your own has never once been questioned or held you back.
I believe the Wales of today and the future
will be owned by all those decent people
who recognise that our Parliament and our government
should look like our country.
People who recognise that our hope and ambition for the future
relies on unleashing the talent of all of us.
A Wales recognizes that we can celebrate our differences
and take pride in all those things that draw us together
and make us who we are. That is the Wales that I want to lead.
A Wales full of hope, ambition and unity.